[Music]
hey how's it going guys it's marquez
from the mkbhd channel back finally back
it's been so long uh but we're finally
back here on youtube with update 6.0 so
the wait is finally over i'm finally
back here on youtube and you guys
probably have a lot of questions and
i've seen them on things like twitter
and facebook and the social networks
that i've been keeping up with you guys
on so just to let you know where i've
been i've been basically focusing on
academics and i'm not done focusing on
academics but i'm finally back to being
on youtube so for the new guys the mkbhd
youtube channel is really tech oriented
channel as you guys have probably seen
the videos already we cover hardware
reviews software reviews and then we do
things like giveaways and even a couple
playlists like forum fridays and a look
back at old gadgets so the two social
networks i've been keeping up with you
guys on has expanded to three so we're
using twitter facebook and google plus
those three links you can check out and
also be in the description which i'll be
carefully maintaining from here on out
with all the videos i post if you guys
could be really nice and just give a
thumbs up to this video that would
really help to spread to let people know
that i'm back or those of you who
thought i was dead or forgot about me so
a thumbs up really helps anyway this is
a really short video to let you guys
know that i am back it's official no
more leaving youtube no quitting i'm
here to stay and open your suggestions
in the comments about what types of
videos you'd like to see there's lots of
views uh gadgets that i've you know had
that i haven't reviewed yet specifically
the zoom back here or my monitors or
maybe a desk tour i don't really know
but uh let me know what you think and uh
thanks for watching this video thanks
for rating and thanks for subscribing
talk to you guys later
peace
[Music]
you